يمكنك سماع مراكز الاقتراع حتى
قبل أن تراهم ، لقد أصبح الأمر أكثر
فظاعة من المنافسات ، كل مركز اقتراع
ذهبنا إليه في جميع أنحاء
مدينة القاهرة يحتوي على مكبرات الصوت هذه التي
تنفجر أطفال الموسيقى الوطنيين في
الشوارع وهم يرقصون بقمصان تقول
اخرج من القارب  لكن في الحقيقة يتلخص
بين رجلين لديك الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي
والمنافس غير المعروف موسى مصطفى موسى
، وبينما لا يمكننا أن نسأل الناس بموجب القانون من
صوتوا لكل شخص تحدثنا
معه لم نخجل منه.
حماسهم لشاغل المنصب
لسنوات لا يكفي ، فقد يكون كافياً
لوضع رؤية ولكن لا يكفي
تنفيذها ، ولهذا السبب
سترى بوضوح تعرف لمن قمت بالتصويت
الآن
هناك 11000 مركز اقتراع في جميع أنحاء
مصر مثل هذا.  مرشحان
للاختيار من بينهما ، وبينما يعتبر الفائز
أمرًا مفروغًا منه إلى حد ما ، فإن
التحدي الحقيقي هو اللامبالاة بالناخبين ، إلا أن
الحكومة تعمل جاهدة للحصول على
التصويت  o أعطِ الرئيس القادم تفويضًا قويًا ،
حافزي للمجيء إلى هنا
لأعطي صوتي لأنني أشعر أنه
يجب أن أكون إيجابيًا حتى لو قلت
نعم أو لا ، فإن صورة الرئيس
CeCe ملصقة حرفيًا في كل مكان هنا في منزله في Gamellia  في
القاهرة ، حتى أن الأمر يتعلق بمركز الاقتراع
، ولهذا السبب وصف العديد من المراقبين
هذه الانتخابات بأنها هزلية
، يقولون إن المعارضة حقًا لم
تتح لها الفرصة أبدًا وأن هذا
استفتاء على الرئيس أكثر من كونه
انتخابًا لي سي إن إن حيرام.